foreign
[Music]
the king
let's keep asking
Maybe
[Applause]
[Music]
massage of you maybe
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and what I think the choir was
only sing
oh they did
[Music]
I
[Applause]
am
[Music]
[Applause]
Maybe
foreign
[Music]
hey friends I hope you enjoyed watching
that Flo dance as much as I enjoyed
creating it I've definitely got a thing
for uh New Wave Revival bands and that
song was especially fun so uh I had a
good old time dancing around to it uh
real quickly a big old thank you to
flowtoys for sponsoring this video and
giving me a reason to go out and play
around with different music and also of
course with their amazing POI if you'd
like to grab a set of those pod POI with
FBC tethers like I was using in this
video you can do so by heading on over
to flowtoys.com and using my special
promo code drexfactor 2023 with a 3
instead of an e and a zero instead of an
O at checkout yes the code has changed
that'll get you a discount on anything
in the flow toy store and even better
than that it'll help out the channel so
go check that out please and thank you
and thank you once again to flow toys
for sponsoring these monthly videos
speaking of thank yous I owe a big one
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
too dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel That is Becca becklonen thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission
and finally this video would not be
possible or not for the kind sport of
all of these amazing people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get early access to all of my
content as well as a host of other
awesome perks so go check that out
please and thank you if you'd like to
see some of my other flow dance sessions
I will include a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video here based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace